[Musica]
avrete sentito parlare di immigrazione e
di migranti ultimamente giusto un po
vagamente avrete sentito di storie di
stranieri che invadono il nostro
territorio le nostre città
storie di migranti su imbarcazioni di
fortuna che attraversano il mediterraneo
che giungono fino alle nostre coste
alcuni loro perdono anche la vita nel
tentativo avrete sentito anche per
restare positive di rifugiati che
decidono di donare i fondi a loro
destinati ai terremotati italiani per
esempio o di migranti che intraprendono
attività commerciali che funzionano
la storia della migrazione è la storia
dell'uomo ed è una storia che parte da
molto lontano anche nella mia famiglia
ad esempio mio nonno emigrato dal
salento al belgio negli anni cinquanta
inizi degli anni cinquanta in
corrispondenza del disastro di
marcinelle dove persero la vita tra gli
altri 136 minatori italiani nei genitori
si sono spostati da sud verso nord
italia iniziò lavorato moltissimi anni
in svizzera e io stesso ho passato tre
anni della mia vita a londra in
inghilterra a fare un dottorato di
ricerca anche se nell'immaginario
collettivo non ero un migrante ero un
italiano all'estero o un expat secondo
un vocabolo che si sta affermando sempre
di più come nella mia famiglia
sono convinto che anche molte delle
vostre famiglie ci siano storie simili
di emigrazione e c'è un filo conduttore
di queste storie un unico filo che
l'emozione le emozioni in chi la vive
che vi racconterà che una delle
esperienze più intense che abbia mai
passato nella vita e l'emozione in chi
la osserva da una certa distanza
l'informazione la politica è sempre di
più i social si nutrono di queste
sensazioni istintive finiscono anche con
avere un impatto sulla nostra percezione
specialmente su tematiche come quelle
della migrazione
non è un caso che secondo l'ultimo
eurobarometro che è il servizio della
commissione europea che guarda alle
tendenze dell'opinione pubblica
l'immigrazione è la principale causa di
preoccupazione dei cittadini europei
è seguito dal terrorismo per contro solo
il 37 per cento degli intervistati si
ritiene informato sulla migrazione su 19
paesi sul 28 la percezione del rapporto
fra immigrati extra europei e
popolazione e di più del doppio di
quello che non sia in realtà in italia
chiedo poi secondo voi qual è la
percentuale di immigrati extraeuropei in
italia chi pensa tra lo zero il 10 per
cento
anzi la mano a metà tra il 10 e il 20
per cento
un po meno tra il 20 e 30 per cento
qualcuno oltre il 30 nessuno minore la
percezione in italia media e del 24,6
per cento quando in realtà i dati ci
dicono che solo 7 sono immigrati su 100
abitanti in italia
questi sono i dati ufficiali questo 7
per cento ed io vi parlerò di dati oggi
sono andata scientist e quello che amo
dei dati e che difficilmente mentono ma
possono essere utilizzati per sfatare
dei miti degli stereotipi ad esempio in
africa
il numero maggiore di migranti si muove
all'interno del continente è solo una
parte di loro finiscono verso altri
continenti quindi non c'è un esodo di
massa verso l'europa
oppure il flusso di messicani verso gli
stati uniti è minore di quello che dagli
stati uniti va verso il messico molti
sono migranti di ritorno che si
ricongiungono ai loro familiari
questo dato riguarda sia i regolari che
regolari sicuramente un dato che in
controtendenza rispetto alla percezione
alla narrazione e c'è stata trasmessa
negli ultimi tempi al joint research
centre della commissione europea
ospitiamo un centro di conoscenza sulla
migrazione alla demografia è uno dei
compiti principali di questo centro e di
mettere ordine nei dati capire dove sono
disponibili capire quali sono le
limitazioni e cercare di migliorare la
situazione
un altro dato interessante è la
percentuale di migrante a livello
globale
questo grafico ci dice che negli ultimi
20 30 anni il rapporto non è variato
molto la popolazione da un lato cresce a
livello globale e il numero di migranti
crescono a livello globale ma il loro
rapporto non varia sensibilmente
quello che cambia sono i flussi le
direzioni l'europa è sempre stato negli
ultimi qualche decennio fino a qualche
decennio fa un punto di partenza
adesso prevalentemente un punto di
arrivo anche se dal sud europa si
continua a partire molto i dati ci
aiutano anche a capire una relazione che
è molto poco conosciuta ed è sicuramente
poco intuitiva ed è fra la crescita fra
lo sviluppo economico di un paese ed i
flussi di immigrazione
siamo portati a pensare che ed ai paesi
più poveri che cittadini emigrino di più
questo non è vero anzi è vero l'opposto
perché non hanno né gli strumenti
nell'aspirazione per farla e solo quando
il loro sviluppo economico cresce che i
flussi crescono fino a raggiungere il
picco di questa curva che detta la gobba
della migrazione oltre la quale le
opportunità che si troverebbero fuori
dal paese di origine equivalgono più o
meno a quelle del paese di partenza
destinazione quindi i flussi cominciano
a scendere
con questo non voglio dire che dobbiamo
smettere di aiutare i paesi più poveri
perché abbiamo un obbligo morale di
farlo ma lo dobbiamo aspettarci che i
flussi diminuiscano al crescere dello
sviluppo economico
un altro dato importante ci dice che
l'emigrazione in sé è un aiuto allo
sviluppo dei paesi di origine
i soldi che mandano i migranti alle loro
famiglie di origine le rimesse
costituiscono uno strumento finanziario
che eccede di gran lunga quelli che sono
gli aiuti diretti dai paesi più ricchi
verso i più poveri
tutti questi dati servono a ricavare
questi bellissimi grafici questa
informazione questa conoscenza siamo
dati raccolti in decine di anni da
decine di paesi e messe insieme da
organizzazioni internazionali come la
banca mondiale
le nazioni unite è uno stato in europa
ma questi dati e le statistiche
ufficiali non ci dicono quello che sta
accadendo nell'immediato e non ci dicono
anche alcune caratteristiche socio
economiche demografiche che sono
fondamentali per
delle politiche adeguate sulla
migrazione in questo abbiamo una buona
notizia
abbiamo un gruppo di lavoro
internazionale col quale lavoriamo e
abbiamo analizzato a quelle che sono le
sorgenti alternative per descrivere la
migrazione i big data e una di queste
possibili vie è offerta dai social
stessi ci sono delle piattaforme
attraverso le quali si possono fare
delle inserzioni pubblicitarie
perché visto nei vostri feed bene se
avete un prodotto e volete
pubblicizzarlo per esempio a expat
italiani in inghilterra maschi in una
fascia d'età dai 35 e 40 anni
facebook linked in twitter vi
restituiscono un numero su base del
quale poi vi chiederanno il conto ma è
un numero di persone che raggiungerete
se facesse questa inserzione
pubblicitaria bene se poi cambiate il
genere è cambiata la fascia d'età
e cambiatele expat dalla francia alla
spagna o dagli stati uniti alla russia
sequenzialmente è possibile costruire un
censimento in tempo reale e a livello
globale ed è quello che abbiamo fatto
per dimostrare il valore di questo
questa è un'analisi che riguarda i
venezolani in spagna venezolani stanno
ammirando moltissimo
molti di loro finiscono con le migrare
in spagna per ovvie ragioni culturali
i dati delle statistiche ufficiali sono
con cadenza annuale arrivano fino al
gennaio del 2017
e poi c'è un vuoto che può essere
colmato con dati nazionale in questo
caso del registro della popolazione
spagnolo che arriva il gennaio del 2018
in giallo con facebook è possibile
completare questa serie è da capire che
il trend ricostruirlo fino ad oggi in
valore inestimabile dal punto di vista
la conoscenza di quello che sta
succedendo in questo momento
stessa cosa per l'ict in che è il social
per le relazioni professionali e
possibile fare la stessa cosa in questo
caso abbiamo chiesto all'inter di dirci
dove sono le utenze il numero di utenti
di che hanno studiato in siria che
probabilmente quindi sono siriani e dove
si trovano adesso in europa e questa è
la mappa che viene fuori la
distribuzione che vedete è molto simile
e riflette fedelmente quella che era di
stelle
funzioni vede richiedenti asilo che sono
recentemente arrivati in europa
quello che non vi dice questa mappa che
siamo in grado anche di capire qual è la
distribuzione di ingegneri di infermiere
di dottori di insegnanti e da
un'informazione fondamentale per le
politiche a livello comunitario ma anche
nazionale e locale per l'integrazione e
la coesione sociale
ovviamente questi dati devono essere
trattati con cautela ci sono delle
questioni di tipo etico di tipo di frye
di privacy di sicurezza
il fatto che non abbiamo controllo su
questi social anche dal punto di vista
degli account molti di noi probabilmente
non hanno nemmeno account alcuni ne
hanno più di uno quindi dobbiamo
correggere per tutte queste cose e
probabilmente non arriveremo mai però a
una sostituzione delle statistiche
ufficiali perché quelli sono affidabili
hanno un processo che è rodato nel tempo
quindi faranno da complemento a questo
molto probabilmente e ci daranno delle
indicazioni che non riusciamo ad avere
nelle statistiche ufficiali di oggi
questi dati sono fondamentali ma se non
gli diamo un contesto non vogliono dire
molto
io ho un dato posso gridare fortissimo e
farlo diventare enorme però se poi li
mette un contesto l'opposto smascherate
le possa rimettere in riga diciamo bene
l'informazione che noi estraiamo dai
dati alla conoscenza è una fase
altrettanto importante che è quella
della raccolta del dato e questi dati
abbiamo capito che sono fondamentali per
le politiche
questi dati ci dimostrano in questa
conoscenza ci dimostrano che la
migrazione non è un fenomeno
emergenziale ma una parte strutturale
della nostra società è ineludibile
non ci possiamo fare niente
probabilmente destinata anche ad
aumentare
probabilmente a rimanere costante e
difficilmente diminuirà quindi quella
cosa che possiamo fare l'unica a
gestirla al meglio cercare di sfruttarne
il potenziale magari affrontare qualche
sfida che già stiamo vedendo adesso è
che nel futuro ci coinvolgerà molto
quali l'invecchiamento demografico o la
richiesta o la mancanza di manodopera in
determinati settori
i dati però se li mettiamo
pronto con la percezione sappiamo
benissimo che non hanno nessun effetto
anzi parliamo di età della post ferita
posta c'è un motivo
quindi questo caso forse per la
percezione è bene confrontarci di più
con le storie dei singoli
le storie di quei migranti dei tuoi
familiari amici conoscenti che abbiamo e
voglio lasciarvi con un invito invito a
chiedere loro di raccontarvi la loro
storia se avranno tempo e disponibilità
sarà emozionantissimo e vi racconteranno
di difficoltà incredibili di emozioni e
di sacrificio ma anche di soddisfazioni
soddisfazione magari di avercela fatta
come nel caso di con carlos è arrivata
in italia dal perù circa 20 anni fa ed è
solo con questa empatia con queste
emozioni che possiamo affrontare la
percezione di quella pancia che ci fa
vedere la realtà e il mondo diversi da
quello che sono
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]